this is We Need to Talk mm-hmm
goes down smoother the more you drink it
yeah it's uh Passos fine we just turned
alcoholics yeah we have no real reason
to drink yeah we're just like you know
it's good this is good stuff no this is
a good episode um again it's funny cuz
the last episode talks so much about
fusion and this one it's or at least we
thought it until we see this episode
it's like no this is the one that really
talks about fusion um we see Connie and
Steven fuse again and then they fall
apart and the father so adorable and
that they really are freaking the door
oh and the father explains about his
past experience quote-unquote fusing uh
with rose we got to see their band the
crystal gem in the Holograms definitely
um are you in the gem vibe from that oh
yeah literally gem by its assisant yeah
I mean it's it's both with a gieta J
yeah um and yeah that was good let's say
though I want to thought that one on
just like just a hit to the song out of
May because it's like well I need to
show you this videos like oh what's it
gonna be and it's this song I'm like do
what you're supposed to be talking about
it's really ten minutes man you know
what 80s awareness there you go I have
to expose the children to what we grew
up with and that's a super nitpick
though um I did Oh pearl
what a bitch yeah hi
I actually like I have no problem if a
character's being mean if it feels like
it's organically written into the story
and I'm like no that would be a reaction
she's literally jealous like I know I
got that I understand that and you know
I like the fact that her plan went awry
um well it's one of those getting girls
still my favorite character I could
totally admit him like oh she's she's
got issues it's one cat issue it's one
of the things where you see I like one
she says it looks like Rose is really
into him
if his you know her favorite thing to I
like that she can't pick now like she's
not in super denial or anything like
that but no she's just like obviously
super I'm gonna put a stop to this mmm
I'm gonna let you finish but first let
me just say she my well and again it
does kind of show you know the again I
mean what we already know what prolem
Rose by me the whole fusion thing I mean
you did see them actually fuse I love
these designs of these fusions I mean as
soon as you found out you find out make
your eyes and I mean as soon as you find
out they can do is it's like God the
opportunities hurl quartz or rainbow
quartz I mean both morally silly yeah um
as well as they I know that if I don't
do it it's like oh man what they can do
and they take advantage of it and they
show all these different view looks like
a lost character from Gemma the hologram
yeah like sort of the well those the
socks that the ankle socks or whatever
those are
oh yeah the spandex thing and everything
Diplo's like a workout video um I need a
hero and I like seeing that young ambos
do I like even though okay I don't drink
how that works cuz if they're like
thousands of years old you know the
father's got to be whatever in his 20s
now he's in like his 50s so how in that
span of time did she grow that much
because if I was a young amethyst is
just like a dog go fetch give us privacy
um it yeah I did like the Marx Brothers
reference to like yeah that is kind of
what they remind me of when compared to
rose it's like she's kind of the serious
one the patriarchy and you got these
three kind of Stooges well I really like
I like seeing garnet not be in command I
like seeing her being like the second in
command because words was obviously she
kind of what that's the thing that the
funny thing is okay amethyst in no way
is ever in command yeah um but I feel
that with Rose gone the duties are split
between garnet and pearl cuz pearl
definitely is assumed sort of a she's
kind of the worrier side of things we
need to do this this and I because I'm
worried this would happen garnet has a
kind of leadership capability of let's
kick ass but Rose seems like she was the
complete package yeah Rose seems like
she has on now she
rolling it up until she had the
tentacles she had the strength and
everything you know she had the details
where it kind of excels that any of them
complete basically the three of them
equal one row yeah
like roses all of their personality
traits rolled up into one which is why I
like that garnet is still can't Lee
cause pearl is great at sort of having
like you know the details and be very
precise and stuff as you see she can get
jealous you get emotional stuff where
garnet is very much more middle of the
road and for the most part you know much
more in control um so you know obviously
you can see beforehand she was almost
like kind of a muscle like the bodyguard
or whatever like if she had the cool
shades and maybe yeah give him privacy
you know hey you want some advice you
know like she has a detachment of garnet
that could be off-putting I feel like
that's her weakness oh yeah oh no no
detect exactly runnable amethyst is
immature um you know and and pearls
strength is she worries because she's
neurotic but that's also her weakness
yeah I think without pearl there they
would end up getting him way more
trouble because they wouldn't consider
the consequences of things so yeah she's
kind of the conscience but it ya know so
it's interesting to see them outside of
their current element when I am
basically in a situation where they're
actually the subordinates well I think
you could see an interesting you know
serve connection with you I didn't think
of it until now that you know with the
human and the gem you know a rose and
him talking and I like that they do show
she doesn't get it you know that this
human thing oh she's like I'm not human
I'm trying to get cuz they and he find
out more and more the fusion really is
the way it's like cuz its fee i
breathing feels like an arranged
marriage what's gonna say i first never
say like if they how they reproduce if
they're just gems they're just kind of
mind and found or whatever you know and
then they just sort of become people oh
it doesn't join some years ago the earth
was a molten man no but i'm say that
there is no it sounds like there's no
real sex there's no real but like the
fusion is the closest thing they have
you know there's no real reproducing
making our person roses count like the
first person who was i jump to do it
dirty mind when Steven and that kotti
fused yeah that sort of concept just hit
me in' and when he's just like she's
like don't tell my parents I'm like oh
my god I won't say these okay since it's
okay Steven just don't get it pregnant
um so you know it's one of those things
where it's like yeah I feel like I'm
getting close and good cuz even pearl
says well no matter how close you get it
doesn't matter cuz you can't fuse you
know so it seems like that's like there
well now we put that wrong closest thing
this x1 okay even but Steven it even
steven um is a you know he's half human
and half
I like this institution well that's why
at the away that's what he's like yeah
you know human are human at talk to any
served touches the pearl like he's he's
not fully one thing you know he oh yeah
I know that I want an ending more sound
like one yeah like I got the impression
just like what am i well and that's
again talking about identity and I think
with uh with him being a human and Rose
being a gem and then trying to connect
trying to find them around well I mean
but it's like they're two extreme things
and Steven somewhere in the middle and
yet with both of them it's like there's
or all three of them there's this
connection there's again trying to find
that identity and I think it's very much
trying to show it's it's not a bad thing
I feel very much like that very much a
culture thing you know where it's like
oh well you're from this culture so you
like this you're from this culture you
like that and there can be exceptions
there can be people that can defy that
and it it's fine if anything it opens up
to more variety more options whole
concept of like racial purity and all
that is so far gone now like it's
impossible like you well I mean we
become the elder eyes to a point and
it's the same thing with cultures it's
like it's like when people talk about
well that's not authentic Chinese food
because it's chinese-american well they
were Chinese and they came here and they
adapted it so it's its own cool thing
well that's what I feel like it whatever
it's like well no no it has to be this
algebra dad Brit ultra this authenticity
is are being made oh yeah authenticity
is so overrated
what's its dis what drives you nuts
about the anime community it's like if
any poor shmuck north american
tries to incorporate a few Japanese
words and develops cuts who the fuck you
weep of don't don't even bother trying
it's like why can't somebody fucking
enjoy something like I would rather
somebody like enjoy a culture and you
know pick up certain aspects of and it's
like I took German I say German words
occasion it's like some real German
Santa's like don't don't even but I'm
what fuck you the funny thing is I find
it's often people like in the other
culture that do them in culture the
Japanese don't give a fuck
half the time they're like what if they
think it's cute sometimes I you know but
meanwhile it's like people here it's
like I can't even just I'm like well
when I teach Japanese Jesse Joyce shit
why is he a Japanese movie or anime
where somewhere they're saying like
American words or any foreign movie or
anything where they say bets will win
forget Engrish is yeah that's cute
that's not you know it's I don't think
that how dare you even try that's in our
language I be it's like no that's on the
funny thing it's unlike the Japanese are
doing it all the time the amount of
Engrish that goes on over there is
hilarious this is you know and it's not
like we're ever gonna pronounce Japanese
right unless you probably live there for
20 years but that's the fun of it never
get joy it for cry see yeah well and I
think that's always the thing it's like
you know everyone's like oh well these
it's good to have culture it's good to
have identity but when you're like this
is it there's nothing else to me not mix
up see identities nati people try to
like segregate it's like oh that's fine
just separate but equal' fuck that ya
know there's a lot of words and that's
not just that's just groups in general I
find that is one of the downsides of
group culture is that you know they are
like well we're the blank and you're the
blank so winner is unless at this and
nerds are some of the most biggest
asshole - and I mean I don't care if I
get shit for this I have seen in my
lifetime nerd culture go from something
where it was kind of like oh we're kind
of like counterculture and we're doing
our own thing and oh the jocks make fun
of us - now we're the fucking job
treating others like chickens like oh
well you're not a real comical fan of
like oh well you just read the top you
don't know jack-shit go fuck yourself
let somebody enjoy whatever the fuck
they want
like the way it's gone full circle in my
lifetime it really fucking disgust me
sorry is what I ran there but yeah yeah
just say how much I love it I'm just
fuckin saying yeah talk about how it's
unfair to judge other group says you
just judged them but but no what we're
takes oh my dress tight a nice peopie
judge other groups that judge that's the
end listeners when you were talking to
them yeah let him know that's my biggest
pet right I know you're talking about
other people that just judge other
people for dude like I see it in a group
but there is something as much as that
sucks there is something finance like it
does show no group is you know away from
this every group does this especially if
it gets big enough you know geek media
has become like this huge thing now so
of course there's gonna be PS well I was
a getting the hipster thing I was a geek
before you were a geek you're not a true
geek you're not a true gamer you're not
a Jew you know true whatever just do
what you want there's nothing there's no
true anything yeah we're all like a
million flavors of much like Buddhism
and life's an illusion so and that's why
I like about this show it does show very
much like you know there's just so many
combinations and so many cultures and so
much that so much you can mix together
and there's just so much more
opportunity and so much more
intelligence and so much more wisdom so
much you can learn from combining these
things rather than you know trying to be
like Oh authentic or one thing or keep
it separate so I like all the
combinations I like the opportunities
that you can fuse with that diversity
man it's a beautiful thing stop harshing
my buzz Manson yeah we we really have
probably had too much of this stuff but
um ya know with that said shit turn me
into angry I won't say that that's again
great thing about this show that's why I
love that it's for kids and that it's
for adults too obviously we can talk
about we can get drunk talking about but
you know it's something that you know
you teach them while they're young and
you open them up to these ideas uh so I
love that I think this is such a good
show for doing that um so yeah that's
about it
uh we'll see in the next one um after
our AAT
I have a problem Adam I'm running out I
have a problem too